let's talk about family law because this
is an important component
um i had no idea what family law was uh
like to be honest with you when i got
married
um it was a big big surprise and
i learned about a lot of stuff myself
personally
first hand experience i learned a lot of
stuff browsing a lot of divorce forums
if you want to let me put it to you this
way
if you want to scare the [ __ ] out of
your 18 year old son
as he's kind of graduating high school
take him to
a um a family court afternoon
and just sit in there and watch what
happens to guys watch
watch how family law treats guys or
alternatively you can let them you know
sit through and browse through you know
things like
divorce forms so you can understand the
concept that was just the tip of the
iceberg for me then i ended up talking
to
several hundred guys through coaching
sessions that have been dealing with
similar types of situation you start to
see that there's a pattern that
evolves out of all of these behaviors
this book by the way guys
this is a collection of stories and
experiences and conversations
most men should have had with their
fathers but never did so i've basically
taken
everything that i thought that was the
most important lessons that i've learned
over the last
number of years that i've been running
the channel especially talking about the
stuff that i have been
specifically for the last few years and
i've distilled it all in the book so
this specific chapter on
why smart men don't marry anymore it's
relevant from all of those experiences
this
this is the most up-to-date information
that i can provide with you guys
today so anyway i was dead wrong about
uh
family law and divorce um one of the
things that really stood out he said to
me if you have the penis and go to court
you're going to lose and badly
okay these were these were the words of
my family lawyer
and i thought to myself at the time well
you know hadn't feminism level the
playing field aren't women equal to men
you know
why am i being told by default that i'm
going to lose and badly
because i was born with a johnson
hanging between my legs right
they say that the original intent of
these progressive changes this is what i
heard
anyway from family lawyers was to deal
with the deadbeat dads that didn't look
after their kids right well
it dealt with that and then it kept
going and became a supremacist movement
that took away all the power from men
and it hasn't stopped and it's given all
of that authority to the state and to
women now
right so if you get married in the west
today
don't think for a second that you're the
man that you're the boss that you're in
charge
you can't out alpha the state or a woman
that is scorned or wants to bounce on
you you just can't it's
it's just not possible you can have
solid frame you can be a top shelf guy
and hope things don't go that way
and hey maybe you end up in the you know
like the top two percent that live in
bliss or the top 13
that still live in romantic love maybe
that will happen
but the chances are what i'm going to
talk about over here
is going to be the more probable outcome
right so 50
chance you're going to end in divorce uh
let's talk about some of the trump cards
the most
interesting one that i came across um
see actually sorry i'm gonna back up a
little bit because i made an important
point here in the book
um you know we talk about the people
that get divorced
and then we talk about the people that
are still living in bliss which is a
very small percentage
there's no real official way to know the
number of people that still stay married
that are like
off the chart unhappy with where they're
at but they either don't have the
courage
the financial resources the balls
whatever you want to call it to leave
that marriage
or maybe it's not financially feasible
there could be a whole bunch of reasons
but they're living in a state
essentially of inc
of incarceration they've they've signed
up for a jail sentence
when they end up in that category
because they can't get divorced and
they're not
romantically blissfully in love so
there's somewhere in the middle and it's
not a good place in the middle cause if
they could leave then they would
generally leave so there's something
holding the back
they're not you know they've been
married for 7 years and they blimped out
and got fat and there's no chance of one
leaving the other because
they're not going to do any better on
the other side of the fence and they
know it they may not have the financial
resources maybe they rely on each other
um schedule wise for children i don't
know there could be any number of things
but they're certainly not off to new
pastures and they're certainly not
living in bliss right
you